[Music]
i wanted
to show you that so if you follow me on
instagram
you know what that is our anniversary
just passed recently
we have now been together casey and i
for
nine whole years we've been married for
four years we've been together for nine
we like to count from the beginning
because we moved in
together since like the six month mark
so it's pretty much like we've been
married this entire time but yeah so
on our wedding day in paris when we got
married we actually forgot to take a
photo of the three of us like
casey isaac and i every time i think
about our wedding and every time i look
at our wedding photos
i'm always like so angry and sad
all these emotions because of the fact
that we didn't get a photo of the three
of us
i know people were wondering on my
instagram like how come you guys didn't
get a picture of the three of you well
what happened was
that day we just like turned our brains
off and we were like okay
we were just doing whatever the wedding
planner was telling us to do we were
posing for whatever photos the
photographer had his pose for and like
we didn't request anything we were just
like going with the flow yeah like we
just completely forgot
to ask for a photo of the three of us so
part of me is like
loki kind of placing i don't want to say
the blame
but like i i'm a little bit peeved
that the photographer didn't think of
taking a photo of the three of us i
guess is what i should say but
ultimately though it was my fault if i
wanted it i should have asked for it and
i totally forgot so anyway all these
years i'm always like dang it i wish we
had a photo of the three of us
and so casey was so freaking sweet and
romantic
and he actually painted this he said
that he hid for
two let me ask well first of all here's
a close-up of it look how beautiful
look at this he did that he painted that
you painted that for me yes i did you
gave it to me for our anniversary
yes i did it's actually the first time
i've ever like
crafted anything for you as a gift i
know that was so
sweet and then i was crying my eyes out
it was so funny because i was just like
oh my gosh the three of us you actually
painted the three of us you got us our
portrait that we just you knew what's up
yeah i was like oh my god it's so sweet
so tell me all about
your thought process like how you were
able to paint this without me even
knowing
i was really impressed on the fact that
you you spent two months you said
about two months i mean it's not two
months of painting it's just
two months of hiding mainly and then
maybe a couple of days worth of painting
because it's like i really
really just had to wait for you to leave
and so it was like small spurts of like
planning like how it's gonna be framed
and i like the composition and stuff and
then like i
drew it for a couple of days but like
that's like really just a couple of
hours once i
started painting that was actually the
trickiest part because i would wait for
you to leave for your errands and then
i would have to paint but then i have to
like kind of guesstimate like when you
be back and i'd be like one hour before
that i need to stop painting because i
need a second drawing so i can like hide
it somewhere and i won't like smear
paint everywhere
so yeah it was uh and i know i'm like
kind of notorious for like not being the
best at
like surprises i have a terrible poker
face and like i'm
i just give things away so i'm like
really
uh happy that i was able to pull this
one off yeah you totally did
there's a couple times we were like in
the garage just like rummaging through
things that's like
oh cause that's why you had to hit yeah
i know it's so funny because every time
he tries to surprise me with something
like
it'll be like a tiny little detail that
he could
like you could easily get away with
playing it cool but because of that one
little
detail hiccup or something you end up
panicking
and then you're just like you're like
okay fine here here's the truth and i'm
like that was so
easy to cover up but okay yeah so
no i'm really proud of you for pulling
this one off too
you were saying that you had an
accomplice yes isaac was my accomplice i
would find times when you were in the
house i was actually like that's really
ballsy now that i'm thinking back at it
i was like
sure just waited for when you left but
like sometimes you were still in the
house but you're like i knew you were
busy with something very specific
i almost never leave too so it was
exactly that was the hardest part he's
like
you're just here and then we go to jake
and news together too and so we're like
and we're always together
it's really hard to find time alone we
really are awesome so yes in the
beginning it was just like oh i know
you're busy
and i would tell isaac hey if mommy
comes down
to the garage you text me asap and then
if she's asking where i'm at just tell
her that i'm working out
and then and i'm gonna pretend that i'm
gonna be out of breath
that was our game plan i didn't know
that actually one time you came you came
down and you're like
where were you i was like oh man i was
in the crowd
i just finished doing some burpees i do
remember that
so you were lying yeah i'm cute
that was good you actually came through
all those times of failing the lie like
it built up to that
yes exactly we're finally but i'm like
secretly i'm like i'm not even sweating
like i just it's
so fake imagine i came over and like
tried hugging you i'm like wait you're
yeah your heart rate is at a resting
rate
yeah you know it'd be like really high
actually oh my god
she's gonna find out the truth
yeah so you're also saying that the
painting you still want to finish it
it's not done yeah i want to take it
back down to like the basics of it and
switch like the color palette
i want it to be less out of the tube if
that makes any sense like a lot of the
colors are like out of the tube and i
didn't really have a lot of time to like
find uh mix it mix it and find a palette
i wanted on some like really
really unique colors and unique tones in
there and i just didn't have time to
like find it if i if i kept everything
as it is
i just gotta do your wedding dress and
then there's a french flag i need to
paint it that's it oh yeah this is a
composite of
three different photographs of one
photograph of me one photographer and
one of isaac and i found one with me
looking
that way and isaac looking this way and
i figured
that'd be really cute so we're both
looking at tiff who is you know like
she's the uh
the star of the day you know oh tell
them about the
background that you picked oh right so i
found
this background like a photo and i was
like oh that's cool we got the eiffel
tower
got the flag in there looks really
parisian perfect
i paint it not thinking anything much of
it and then i give it to tiff
and she's like oh my gosh you even
included the one alleyway we did uh
wedding photos at
yeah so the day after our wedding we
actually booked the photographer
and like we got ourselves made up just
like as if it was the wedding day the
previous day
and we actually rented out a car too
and we drove all around paris taking
photos like
supposed to be like you know very
parisian photo shoot
and one of the locations that the
photographer took us to was this exact
place so i'm like oh my god you even got
the exact place
where you took photos and then you were
like oh really i just googled this place
yeah that's so funny every morning
when i'm brushing my teeth i brush my
teeth right here and i'm just like
staring at it the whole time i'm like
i love it so much it's like the best
gift ever actually
this experience has made me want to do
more uh
paintings yeah you should yeah like i
felt really fulfilled for some reason i
was like
because it's part of your your identity
like being an artist like doing
art and like used to paint a lot this is
like refreshing it's different yeah it's
your art
it's a piece of view so maybe we need to
paint more and maybe we'll have like a
whole like museum
yeah we can replace we can replace the
store-bought
stuff true and actually make it more
meaningful with your art
help me with some subject matter though
because i think the hardest part about
painting right is for me it's like i
don't really know
what i want to paint for this i was like
oh it feels like a really
sentimental idea and like that gave me
the idea to paint that but like normally
i'd be like my painting oh you [ __ ]
i know what you should paint next oh my
gosh i have a perfect idea
or cats so in my a portrait of zoe and
maya but like at the beach
like with some like palm trees and stuff
and then we can hang it over here look
hang it
right there oh
okay you wanted a long ways or landscape
or long ways
it could be a portrait of this guy and
his sister
also we don't have any artwork of you
all right guys it's lunch time now and
we're going to be preparing some
delicious food
from today's sponsor thank you green
chef for sponsoring
today's video green chef is a usda
certified organic company that makes
eating well
easy and affordable with plans to fit
every lifestyle like vegan
vegetarian paleo and keto their expert
chefs design
flavorful recipes that go beyond
ordinary substitutions
recipes are quick and easy they give you
step-by-step instructions
chef tips and photos to guide you along
their ingredients come
perfectly portioned pre-measured and
mostly prepped
which is really good because i'm bad at
prepping it's super easy and convenient
everything is hand
picked and delivered straight to your
door so there's no need to take a trip
to the grocery store
and i didn't know this but green chef is
actually owned by hellofresh which we
already love and enjoy in this household
so it's really cool to switch between
brands
and get to try something different that
we haven't tried before
so i'm a huge fan i absolutely love it
it makes cooking so easy
it makes my husband happy that he
finally has a wife who is in the kitchen
right yes
so make sure to go to green chef dot u s
slash 90 tiff case and use code 90 tiff
case
for 90 off your very first box plus free
shipping once again that's green chef
dot
u s slash 90 tiff case use code
90 tip case to get 90 off
plus free shipping on your very first
box and enjoy
[Music]
all right guys now we're on our way to
a friend's reunion yes we are on our way
to the hollywood forever cemetery which
is where the event is going to take
place
and shout outs to nikki because she
invited us so thank you nikki
she was invited to go to this event and
she was allowed to take five of her
closest friends with her
and so she invited obviously you know
gina and jess as well but jess is in the
middle of moving right now
so she's like no way can i make this
event that's way too stressful she's
actually leaving this week and so she's
packing right now it's super busy gina
was like
oh i actually have a friend that worked
on on
the show so i'm good so we're like okay
so then that's why casey's able to come
now and so it's gonna be
me casey or nikki steve me casey and
steve's brother and his girlfriend so
that's the six of us that are gonna be
there
and right now we're gonna go and meet
them up at
the cemetery the cemetery is actually
really cool you've never been home no
this is my first time going to the
cemetery
to watch anything yeah so at the
hollywood farmer cemetery
it's really famous cemetery because
that's where a lot of famous people
are resting they also have this event
called
i don't know how to i don't know how to
pronounce it but it's this really cool
event where
um you can come to the cemetery bring
your own
picnic like your own blankets pillows
and all that stuff and then they
put they have this huge projector and
then you can watch movies and i've
actually
been there once when isaac was
he was like three years old i think i
came with my friend leslie
and isaac and we were all just watching
a movie and i really can't remember what
movie was playing but i
have a feeling it was like the wedding
singer or something i really don't
remember but it was a really fun event
and
now i get to come back with this time
with casey
and friends yeah and friends to watch
the friends reunion yeah it's pretty
cool because
friends the show friends um has always
been one of my favorite shows growing up
and for my first like the first birthday
that i got to spend with casey
he actually got me the friends dvd set
as my birthday gift back when dvds were
still a thing i know
and it's funny because i've tried
watching it because i i
feel bad if i just never opened it and
so like i've tried watching
a few episodes here and there like
throughout the years but it's just not
as easy as like streaming because
now we have friends on netflix i think
or
hp oh now it's hbo but yeah so like it's
just easier streaming but i still have
the friends dvd collection because i
just never wanted to get rid of it
because it was the very first
birthday gift that casey ever gave me
and i thought it was really thoughtful
so i still have it yeah actually i tried
watching
the show a couple days ago and i was
like
oh man this is really outdated like
a lot of the jokes are really outdated
and i don't know if it's my age
i mean obviously just as a society we've
all kind of
changed our perspective on a lot of
different subjects
and i think a lot of us kind of cringe
when we watch that show now but
i also see it from like a 31 year old
lens versus a seven-year-old's
lens because that's when i first watched
the show you were seven when you first
watched yeah started watching friends
i remember i was like seven or eight
yeah i was like 97
as a parent now would you let your
seven-year-old watch friends
in the 90s you know my mom wasn't even
around like i was
it was me and my my closest friend we
would watch
friends after school because they would
be playing um
like after school later and played later
it was like at seven or eight pm or
something that's how late i stayed at
my friend's house because my mom was
working so she would pick me up
after school at her house and
yeah like i remember we would first
watch it was first like pokemon
it would come on and then later on it
was like sabrina the teenage witch
and then sister's sister and then
uh i like watching foreign
oh yeah right but yeah so like i don't
know we just watched a whole bunch of
shows and
after doing homework i would just kill
time and wait for my mom to pick me up
but
but yeah so watching the show now like
with a different
perspective i'm like whoa these
these jokes are so outdated so i'm like
oh man
but i it still holds like a special
place in my heart because
because you know it's nostalgic so i
would not blame
kids these days like isaac for example
we tried getting isaac to watch it
because he's watched friends he like we
just finished watching modern family
which we absolutely loved
and i don't know just friends was just
like
a show that was always near and dear to
me because i grew up with it
and so i tried showing it to him and
isaac's like yeah the show isn't funny
like i'm just i'm not about it
and then i was watching it with him i'm
like yeah dude i don't blame you
it's so outdated i get it go ahead and
keep watching your family guy he likes
watching that too
but and then honestly i'm not very
comfortable that he's watching but that
he's watching that show but i'm like
okay he's 13 now
i can't show for him forever like all
right fine go ahead and watch family guy
but i wish she wasn't watching that show
but it's not like friends is any better
either i mean they have a lot
of inappropriate jokes in that show
probably true
like watching it back now i'm like oh
yeah it's a lot more risque than i
remember
i used to think it was like not risque
at all really not at all i knew it was
risque i remember being a child thinking
like
they're talking about sex anyway we're
getting closer now
so i'll see you there
[Music]
all right we just parked we are
ready for this event this is so cool
because look they gave us a little
program
and then it says that we get concessions
and new york style dinner
photo booths along with drinks on us
unlike joey we like to share food
how cute is that i know right like i
wonder if we're getting pizza
pasta can we get some coffee from
central park
i know i wonder i know my friends
references
nice all right let's go see if we can
find steve and nicky and stupid brother
and his girlfriend
[Music]
mhm